[Music]
what up guys JK news is now available
also as a podcast go in the description
below to click the links it's on iTunes
SoundCloud all kinds of other stuff and
back to you mofo Thank You Wow in :
you were sleeping probably yeah that was
I was impressed by the professionalism
of the husband in caught on camera news
o submitted by Joe's bellybutton the
world of us with Bobby and he was like
40 pounds lighter when we shot the porno
skit he's fat as [ __ ] now huh he gained
a lot of weight since then yo that
[ __ ] beard man is up a camera to
catch a ghost instead catches his
girlfriend having sex with his
sixteen-year-old son like she's sleeping
with the six-year-old he's trying to
catch a [ __ ] ghost he's like I'm
gonna get this ghost like I know it's
here it's probably like a regular
[ __ ] camera 216 ELLs got good dick
though I like the idea of a guy well is
that always coming from you I mean why
is it always coming from you can you
make that joke and you man when I was 16
I remember that she would not go down
he's talking about the boners you get
very old owners yeah now when I was 60 I
came to fast
I will translate for my [ __ ] was like
strong it's not strong anymore he's
gotten weak it was like a diamond saw
it's crazy ya know older you get the
more you have to convince your dick now
it's like come on buddy listen before
you could like hang all the clothes on
your closet on the dip do before I could
pop a bar that would like dent the Jean
material like significantly wear my
jeans out it's split there's just like
this really light blue patch on your
jeans that's right now it's like it goes
up but this is kind of like a kiss but
it's a little reluctant you now I have
to [ __ ] just beat those jeans to
myself like right there this with my
hands
it's like you have to give them a cue
now you have to give your dick acute it
come on then you know what happens come
on man so I can see why she did it I
wouldn't be able to [ __ ] at 16 I [ __ ]
do two pumps and blow I'll be like I
need to take a nap let's do it again but
the recovery time is found it's very
fast - yeah very good you [ __ ] a lot but
then it's just the I just don't [ __ ]
laugh but hey at least you do now
it took me a long time alright so this
takes place in Tasmania and so this man
which I don't know how old he is they
don't mention his age but apparently his
28 year old girlfriend of 11 years was
caught having sex with a 16 year old son
16 year old son yeah I'm trying to do
this man 28 year old girlfriend of 11
years so he got with her when she was
like 17 I don't know okay I don't know
his son was 12 her so she knew the son
when he was like five six years old so
they're saying that she knew the son
since he was 9 years old which I was
like wait there's four years of you
being with him but you don't know the
kid I don't know but anyway she you've
known this kid until 9 this is like the
Anakin Skywalker Natalie Portman [ __ ]
yep where you're like wasn't in the last
movie he was like [ __ ] 3 years old
yeah oh my Star Wars is all kinds of
[ __ ] up I mean you know Luke and uh
he's [ __ ] his sister yeah he [ __ ]
it he [ __ ] her mouth in the episode 4
oh you know you gotta watch it it r2d2
has link in the butt from the back you
see now r2z mass and see cute c-3po came
in jacked off loose weight what I don't
know like where this is a joke or a word
I don't know what this you never saw
Star Wars so you don't know yeah nothing
older one Chewbacca was [ __ ] do the
porn you watch why do you think teenage
boys love Star Wars are you kidding
you've never seen good there lifesaver
girls sometimes it's floppy not 16 year
old dick apparently
good rejoinder anyway back to the so
yeah like like the headline said he was
trying to catch a goat he's like a he's
screwing the Camrys like I'm gonna get
this [ __ ] ghost
how was he trying to catch it go no no
but apparently you forgot to turn the
camera off and then that's when he just
bought the ghost and he comes around ten
hours one night yeah well you saw on
camera was that his girlfriend was like
cuddling and kissing the his son no
which then eventually led to sex it's so
weird too because apparently this couple
had like they have a kid together so
this is like her kids half-brother is
she hot just tell me she's back now I
don't have help me out there's no okay
we're gonna say that she's hot okay okay
why does she moan like a ghost like what
the [ __ ] oh maybe he thought it was a
ghost or he's like just moaning
everywhere in my house is like I know
there's not money come from my son's
room and she's not in his bed like he
wakes up he seems to [ __ ] ghost
because where she is that why he went to
go yeah they don't go into the ghost
detail all it is is that who wrote this
article they don't give you any details
about anything uh tell her garage man
yeah right anyway so then after it was
discovered
apparently they continued to keep the
affair going and I don't know ghosts
yeah so then the woman was sentenced to
six months in prison for raping a kid
yeah and the boy was moved to go live
with his grandparents [ __ ] them if that
was a guy who got caught with a young
lady 30 years oh for sure eight years
yep only six months cause he enjoyed it
yep but because it's only by the way I
agree with this because it was a chick
much lighter sentence
yep and because I think in our heads
were like she's hot she's hot good boy
cuz we put ourselves in the
sixteen-year-old not the 28 year old
that's your stepmom listen no you want
ins you're new but
she's hot and there's no blood relation
so to the comp most commonly the most
commonly searched porn term right now is
like stepkids depth it's very popular
even jeana's friend who's in the porn
industry pouches for that thank you
wrong with you people
I don't like that one they've watched it
so long I think it's as an epidemic
actually I think porn right now and I
hate to say this because it sounds like
nerdy is [ __ ] or it sounds lame as hell
to say but I think it's an it's an
epidemic I think it is and I think that
this is the reason why birth rates are
going down everywhere because they need
to get even more turned cuz people don't
want don't need to [ __ ] as much a girl
would pick up a quarter and I'm like
busted in my pants back in the day
exactly what do you propose porno full
ban a full porn man no absolutely not no
there's nothing to propose I mean it's
just like damn cuz porn is better it's
pretty always gonna be your imagination
never says nothing we can do until we
get [ __ ] robots that match porn so
that when you're watching porn you have
a [ __ ] but it's not a solution it's
actually the solution no one's still
gonna want to [ __ ] or have kids that
makes a horse only rich guys could
experience what they want on porn well
yeah that's true but even those guys are
watching for probably so what G is
saying is that birth rates are gonna
continue to decline under my idea and
I'm saying but light the quality of life
will be so much better for men only for
men that who cares
unless robots like Rick and Morty and I
actually create babies singers
oh that's pretty tight women will get
phased out like that no you won't get
your own sex robots and our bodies are a
little dope yeah
man they won't be we won't have to take
care of them like children yep yep wait
I don't like this idea anymore I like it
I like it
Amy I don't like it I need to create an
EMP weapon to take out all the sex
robots the MP weapon and Electra mating
what kind of agent are you not that is
not okay they used it on [ __ ] Ocean's
eleven remember to take out the whole
you know electricity so they could get
inside
but don cheadle did yeah Don Till's so
funny to me he plays like that
he plays like a tough guy but at the
same time he looks like if I part he
would crumble yeah he's always like this
tough guy but he weighs like a hundred
pounds out of it when is he a tough guy
like I said he always the nerve Boogie
Nights he's basically like everyone's
[ __ ] of that movie he played war
machine he was like the top even when
he's war machine that yeah I think he's
kind of a [ __ ] right I mean crazy he
got a spine broken like a little [ __ ]
I didn't see that yeah he fell out from
the sky in his back broken half oh wait
do we see him in person how do they saw
no I'm zoom see what in person Don
Cheadle's saw Wesley Snipes there yeah
but I thought we saw Don cheeto their
plot your memory your [ __ ] memory is
fun why cuz you remember [ __ ] that never
happened but the [ __ ] that never
happened is really fun shut up G oh by
the way I love Don Cheadle and I love
dogs you yeah I just wanted to say that
this could either be Knights I think
he's my favorite that worked that he's
done Boogie Nights is the one with that
what's-her-name [ __ ] her tits out
Heather Graham yes right absolutely
she is I don't even remember him in that
movie oh he's great I just remember that
one guy and I kept getting his
girlfriend [ __ ] and he just I was like
why do you let life do that to you and
then he [ __ ] ended up going crazy and
I was like that's right that's why you
let him do it yeah he killed himself and
killed her yeah yeah and he killed the
guy yeah guys probably some of the
nicest like naturally it's a nice rack
on like movie earth they're all raisins
now though
well she's older now they were nice and
ripe they were fantastic dude when she
did that American woman music video for
Lenny Kravitz I was like yo
[Laughter]
yes I remember that oh I was like forget
about it
it was crazy Vicky was next to you just
literally pushed her side I'm good I
don't even know Nick even these are the
glory days that's right that's right
that's right we should cut it right here
don't send early feeling detox
[Music]